jusqu'à dresser un tout petit peu le
club vous redresser un petit peu le
buste ok mais super allait très bien ok
pas grave
contactez un tout petit peu au dessus ce
samedi 27 octobre thomas 17 ans a décidé
de participer à un cours d'initiation au
golf de saint quentin en yvelines
la raison le sportif a vibré le mois
dernier devant son écran lors de la
ryder cup 2018
j'ai déjà un peu touché au golf mais ça
m'a fait vraiment donné envie d'y aller
sinon j'aurais peut-être attendu
quelques mois avant de venir plus comme
thomas ils sont des centaines de
débutants avoir testé le golf dans le
complexe depuis la fin de la ryder cup
ça fait un déclic supplémentaires soit
des gens qui regardaient la télé qui
aimait le golfe
voilà et canal + je crois de mémoire a
eu quand même 2,2 millions de
téléspectacteurs donc ce qu'est ce qui
est énorme et donc à beaucoup de gens
grâce à cette ryder cup qui sont venus
me voir
et certains n'ont pas hésité à
s'inscrire dans la structure c'est le
cas de marie la sportive à pratiquer le
golf toutes les semaines avec l'aide
d'un coach
aujourd'hui c'est son deuxième court
c'est un objectif aussi parce que quand
on a envie on a envie de s'améliorer en
orbite ou temps de tirer des papes et
d'améliorer de performance au total le
golfe qui comptait plus de 800 inscrits
a déjà enregistré 100 inscriptions
supplémentaires depuis septembre on a pu
toucher de nouveaux publics
que ça ait de la personne retraitée à
des personnes qui sont encore en train
de travailler à terme le golf blue green
de 50 ans ni ville espère attirer plus
de 1400 adhérents grâce à cet effet
ryder cup